bonsoir claude d'ange besson merci
d'être avec nous le premier ministre qui
se dit donc prêt à des élections
anticipées mais pour bien qu'on
comprenne qu est-ce qu on reproche
précisément à nikol pashinian on lui
reproche trois choses on lui reproche
bien entendu comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure dans votre sujet d'avoir resigné
dans la nuit du 9 au 10 novembre
l'accord de cessez-le-feu qui consacre
la défaite de l'arménie face à aux pays
qu'ils avaient attaqué et cet accord il
a été le sig à moscou il n'avait
d'ailleurs pas le choix et son
état-major à l'époque lui avait demandé
de le faire pour éviter une déroute
totale
le prix était assez élevé puisque
l'arménie a dû se défaire de toute une
zone tampon entre l'arménie à proprement
parler et ni grand ni karabakh qui a eu
probablement plus de dix mille morts
dans cette cette guerre et que l'alarmé
n'iront plus à lui accepté des droits de
passage de l'azerbaïdjan au sud de son
territoire pour relier deux parties de
l'azerbaïdjan qui se trouve à l'est et à
l'ouest de son territoire
donc le prix était était élevé deuxième
reproche que l'on fait à monsieur pacini
et bien c'est celui d'avoir très mal
géré la crise il était arrivé au pouvoir
en 2018 sur un programme de réformes et
de lutte contre la corruption
il s'est retrouvé malgré lui chef de
guerre lorsque il a été attaqué lorsque
son pays a lorsque le leader ni karabakh
a été attaqué par l'azerbaïdjan et par
conséquent il a cru devoir en rajouter
il en a rajouté en disant à son peuple
nous allons gagner c'est sûr il a adopté
un ton extrêmement martial est
naturellement lorsque la défaite s'est
profilée et bien et il n'a pas su faire
les discours qui convenait vis-à-vis de
sa population
donc il a mal géré la crise et je crois
que ça on lui reproche
puis dernier reproche c'est qu'en effet
depuis cette défaite il s'accroche au
pouvoir
les considère qu'il a été élu
démocratiquement ce qui est ce qui est
le cas sur un programme de réformes et
qu'il doit faire ces réformes et qu'il
faut éviter
d'après lui que l'ancienne équipe
revienne au pouvoir pour retourner
revenir aux anciennes pratiques
donc il a été un héros pendant quelques
semaines au début de cette guerre
il a ensuite était un traître au moment
de la signature de l'accord de cessez le
feu est maintenant il est un bouc
émissaire alors l'irruption au club
house maison de l'armée dans le
processus politique est ce qu elle peut
constituer un tournant
probablement pas mais c'est d'ailleurs
tout à fait inhabituelle en arménie
l'armée a toujours montré le plus grand
respect pour les institutions politiques
jusqu'à présent bien sûr elle rêvait
sans doute de faire porter le chapeau de
la défaite au premier ministre à
monsieur pas de signal et celui ci très
maladroitement l'ua a donné l'occasion
le prétexte mercredi dernier lorsque
draps curieusement il a dit que c est
certain certains systèmes d'armement de
fusées et secondaires qui sont
d'ailleurs des fusées fourni par la
russie n'avait pas fonctionné et que
c'était peut-être l'une des causes de la
défaite
or les fuseaux horaires semble-t-il
n'ont jamais été utilisées à ce moment
là puisqu'elle ne correspondait pas à la
condition tactique dans laquelle se
trouvait l'arménie est l'un des chefs
militaires
la reprise a qualifié a qualifié le
frivole ces paroles publiquement et ce
numéro deux de l'armée de l'armée
arménienne a été limogé immédiatement
sans autre forme de procès alors à
partir de là l'état-major dans son dans
son intégralité a réagi et a publié
jeudi la semaine dernière un communiqué
demandant la démission du premier
ministre expliquant qu'il était
responsable de tous les maux de
l'arménie qu'il avait très mal géré le
pays et et ses relations extérieures
donc
l'ue a donc immédiatement proposé au
président de la république de limoges et
le chef d'état-major le chef de l'armée
ce que le président de la république a
refusé alors il semble que ce soir est
un fait nouveau
si le conseil de sécurité se déclare
d'accord avec le premier ministre sur ce
point ça restera évidemment à voir mais
on est dans une situation qui est quand
même très dangereuse puisque il ya deux
blocs qui lie à ceux qui soutiennent
monsieur le premier ministre qui
considère qu' il faut faire des réformes
il faut lutter contre la corruption et
puis se considère qu'il a failli et il
faut qu'il démissionne et qu'il soit
remplacé
peut-être par des gens qui ont déjà
participé auparavant à la direction à la
gestion de l'arménie c'est devant ce
dilemme que l'on se trouve aujourd'hui
et la question globale finalement
quelles sont les perspectives pour
l'arménie
bien sûr la perspective est celle qui a
été tracé ce soir d'abord je crois que
c'est un bon signe que les
manifestations se soit déroulé dans le
bonheur qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
débordement donc des manifestations
pacifiques et il faut en effet que la
majorité du premier ministre et
l'opposition se mettent d'accord pour
organiser le scénario de la dissolution
du parlement et de nouvelles élections
c'est un petit peu compliqué parce qu'il
ya des délais à respecter mais ça peut
se faire en quelques semaines
et effectivement ce sont les élections
qui détermineront qui doit diriger à
l'avenir le canal de gouvernement de
l'arménie
c'est le premier ministre qui a le plus
de pouvoir le président de la république
ayant surtout des pouvoirs de régulation
et des pouvoirs les pouvoirs
protocolaires donc ces élections
seraient très importantes d'autant plus
que l'armée arménienne est en train de
se réformer avec l'aide d'ailleurs de la
russie puisque l'arménie fait partie de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité et
de coopération
c'était une alliance militaire avec la
russie qu'il ya deux bases russes en
arménie
l'arménie fait aussi partie d'ailleurs
de la communauté économique eurasiatique
dont fait également partie
la russie et le kazakhstan donc c'est un
pays dont l'évolution est très
importante pour toute la région du
caucase et puis pour toute la région
au-delà de ça de l'europe de l'est merci
beaucoup
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales